to start the story right if you look at
the databases like Microsoft SQL Server
which is what the focus of our work has
been so far
SQL Server introduced scalar
user-defined functions way back in 2000
as a means for users to be able to
express their custom behavior you know
some of these custom logic is easier
expressed using imperative code so there
was a demand for it and they introduced
this feature it was good and happy but
in a few years people realized that
scalar UDF's are good when it comes to
modularity and code reuse and some other
metrics but with respect to performance
it turns out that they're evil you're
listening to the Microsoft Research
podcast a show that brings you closer to
the cutting edge of technology research
and the scientists behind it I'm your
host Gretchen using
in the world of relational databases
structured query language or sequel has
long been king of the queries primarily
because of its ubiquity and unparalleled
performance but many users prefer a mix
of imperative programming along with
declarative sequel because it's user
defined functions or UDF's allow for
good software engineering practices like
modularity readability and reusability
sadly these benefits of tradition only
come with a huge performance penalty
rendering them impractical in most
situations that bothered dr. Karthik
Ramachandra a senior applied scientist
at Microsoft Research India so he spent
a great deal of his career working on
improving an imperative complement
sequel in database systems today dr.
Rama Chandra gives us an overview of the
historic trade-offs between declarative
and imperative programming paradigms
tells us some fantastic stories
including the tale of two engineers and
the UDF story parts 1 & 2 and introduces
us to Freud
that's fr OID not the Austrian
psychoanalyst
which is an extensible language agnostic
framework for optimizing imperative
functions in databases offering the
benefits of UDF's without sacrificing
performance that and much more on this
episode of the Microsoft Research
podcast
[Music]
Karthik Ramachandra welcome to the
podcast thank you I'm happy to be here
you're a senior applied scientist at the
Microsoft research lab in India in
Bangalore and I'm lucky to have you in
the booth today
good to see you face to face met you at
Tech fest now we're in the booth yeah
tell us what does a senior Applied
scientists do for a living what gets you
up in the morning well as an applied
scientist the good thing about my job is
that I get to ask the really hard
questions which are not commonly asked
and the other thing is I get to work
with really smart people to solve those
problems and the third thing is that the
problems that I saw have a potential of
impacting a huge customer base worldwide
which is very inspiring and exciting to
me and that gets me excited every day
yeah so on the spectrum there there's a
sliding scale of pure research to
applied research or industrial research
where do you fall on that spectrum
because you're working in a pure
research institution really but it has
some play in it right yeah so I like to
place myself in the middle of the
spectrum my interest is in taking ideas
and technologies that are coming out of
pure research outcomes and then coming
up with a way to make them practical or
make them real in real systems and reach
to customers and users so I like being
in the middle there to be a bridge
between research and practice so that's
where I think I would place myself I
love that because as we're going to find
out shortly in this interview you're
also bridging some other kinds of
technologies so maybe that's your
calling in life is to be the bridge well
let's set up our podcast with a virtual
earth 3d view of relational databases
which is the heart and soul of your work
yes tell us about the two main
programming paradigms in the relational
database world and their relative
strengths and weaknesses so we're at
least in a mindset to understand how
your current work is reconciling them
yep so if you look at relational
databases today the primary way to
interact with the database is through
this language called
SQL or structured query language which
falls under this declarative paradigm of
programming which basically says the
user needs to tell the system what they
need in this declarative high-level
language and the system figures out an
efficient way to do what the user has
asked so that's sort of one main
paradigm apply the primary way we
interact with databases today that comes
with the advantage that you know the
users can stay at a higher level of
abstraction not having to go to the
detailed implementation of how things
are done and it also allows the system
to optimize and come up with efficient
algorithms to solve the query or the
question that the user is trying to ask
yeah that is one paradigm and on the
other side we have this imperative
programming style which is a slightly
lower level of abstraction in the sense
you are basically telling the system how
to go about doing what you want it to do
and as a result you're sort of binding
the system to implement it in the way
you are telling it to do the advantage
imperative programming languages is that
you have more scope for modularizing and
reusing code and so on but there's a
limited scope for the system to figure
out efficient ways to do data processing
so declarative you're telling the
computer what to do but not how to do it
it's telling the database what you want
but not how yes and the imperative you
have to know a bit more you have to be
more specific on how you want it to
carry it out it's more like a preference
sort of in many cases you can express
your requirement in either paradigm but
in my opinion it's just a matter of
choice well there you go cuz on the
larger scale we're going to be talking
today about why you're leaning towards
the imperative paradigm and so let's go
there right now I usually try to set my
questions up into progressive somewhat
linear manner but your life and career
and your work all kind of go together
and they're intertwined so I'm gonna go
a little more freeform today and have
you tell us some stories because I know
you're good at storytelling I want to
start with one that will put a finer
point on this declarative imperative
approach the tension between the two you
call it a tale of two engineers you
actually have a name for this story
which I love being a lip major
tell us the story yeah yeah so this is a
tale that I always use when I want to
drive home the point about this problem
so let's say there's this ecommerce
company like an online retail firm right
typically these companies have a large
database of customers who are placing
orders and also the order information
like what orders were placed and so on
so it turns out that in one such company
there is a manager who owns this data
and is responsible for doing some data
analytics on this data and this company
now has this new requirement that they
want to introduce something like a
rewards program where they want to help
loyal customers by having some offers
and so on so they want to basically
categorize their customers into let's
say three categories like platinum gold
and regular and they have some simple
logic to do this if you bought stuff
worth some amount of money or more then
you are platinum otherwise your regular
and so on based on how much business you
do with them you fall into one of these
buckets so she calls two of her
engineers in her team and tells them
look we have this new requirement please
go and implement this and give me a
report it shows all the customers and
which bucket they fall into so it turns
out these two engineers get into a fight
about how to do this I mean this happens
not very uncommon software Wars so it
turns out that these two engineers
decide that they will do it in their own
way and they both go off on their own
one of them happens to be an SQL expert
right so he's done a lot of SQL in his
past years of work so he comes up with
one complex SQL query which can answer
this problem right away right so it's
one query but it does the job but
probably only he can understand it
because it's quite complex the other
engineer is a programmer is not an SQL
expert so he writes a simple query and
writes an imperative user-defined
function which again does the same thing
in a different way right so he rewrites
it using variables and if-then-else and
conditional branching and so on and
different constructs that are common so
now both of them come back to the
manager with
respective solutions both of them think
that their solution is better so they
come to the manager and show their
solution but it turns out that the
manager runs both of those and decides
to promote one of them and fire the
other one so this is a more dramatic
part of the story we may not fire them
but the point is that one of them is
promoted then the other one is not can
you guess the reason I cannot not even I
would imagine you guess who was fired
and who was promoted why I've seen the
slides so I know the end of the story
but I know our listeners down so it
turns out that the SQL expert was
promoted and the imperative programmer
was filed in this case and the reason
being that the SQL query ran in a couple
of minutes over their database of
millions of customers and billions of
orders whereas the imperative function
took a few hours to run on their
database and that was not acceptable to
the business so they had to choose the
more efficient solution despite the fact
that the function had other benefits to
it so this sort of demonstrates that
both solutions are correct they give the
right answer right they're not doing
something wrong but just because you
wrote the program in a different way you
are penalized right so that's the
tension there that I'm trying to
reconcile okay and I love this because I
already know the other end of this story
which is the cool technology you're
working on right now but let's diverge
again because there's some other setups
I want to do normally I wait to have you
tell about yourself till the end of the
podcast but I want you to do that now
since I also happen to know that your
early academic and professional
experiences led directly to the research
you're doing so tell us how the first
job you got after your graduation led to
a nagging dissatisfaction that got you
here now yeah yeah that's actually an
interesting story so as a part of my job
earlier as a software developer and a
tech lead we had this requirement from a
client where we had to build a dashboard
based on a data that was present in a
relational database back-end so we built
a nice little dashboard tool which could
do these reports as the customer wanted
and we used all the good programming
practices by writing modular code and
following all the design patterns that
are recommended and best practices for
programming and so on but it turned out
that the tool that we built although it
was doing its job it failed the
performance requirements miserably
because the scale of the data was huge
and the way we had written our tool it
could not scale to you know large data
sets and multiple concurrent users using
it at the same time so it was basically
not able to match the performance
requirements as a result when we did the
analysis and figure out what was the
reason it turned out that we had to
manually remove some of these good
programming practices and undo some of
these good things that we had done in
terms of software engineering practices
and we had to rewrite a lot of programs
as huge SQL queries which did the job
more efficiently but in terms of
maintainability and other factors we
lost out on something so in some sense
we had to trade-off readability and
modularity for the sake of performance
so we did this and the customer was
happy after that but what left me
nagging with this whole experience was
why should we do this trade-off right is
there a way to get both performance and
this flexibility and this modularity
together I don't want to give up on
either of them right so that's sort of
what got me thinking and when I left my
job and went to grad school at iit
bombay i saw that my advisor was
actually with another PhD student at the
time was doing something very similar in
fact recently they had started looking
at the same problem so that moment I
realized that I had come to the right
place and I just joined them and took
that project forward so that's how this
all started
so did you actually quit your job to go
back to school because you were bothered
by this or was it more complex than that
yeah I mean it was not that I quit my
job and went to grad school purely for
this particular problem yeah I had the
desire to go back to school and go
deeper into some area of computer
science anyway
and this fell in place really well
because this was also a problem that was
at the back of my mind and I saw that my
adviser Sudarshan at iit bombay he was
also looking at the same problem with
another PhD surin so it was just like
something that clicked immediately I'm
just
gonna say - this is a kind of life
wisdom thing get a job after undergrad
before you go back to graduate school to
find out what the real world is doing
and what problems there are and maybe
it'll inspire you for exactly especially
for this applied research areas right
where the problems need to be motivated
by real needs yeah it was really
valuable in hindsight I knew that I
would go to grad school when I took up
my first job but in hindsight it's clear
to me very much that my experience
before getting into grad school has
helped a lot in the research that I've
been doing and all the work that I've
been doing
[Music]
alright well let's keep the story train
going you have another one and it has
two parts I love the fact that you title
your stories this one's called the UDF
story we haven't addressed what UDF is
but it's integral to the imperative
paradigm so tell us the UDF story part 1
and part 2 or how UDF's went from evil
to magic in less than 20 years
that's a nice subtitle for my story
well so UDF stands for user defined
function and it's essentially a wave in
a database system you can have
imperative programs like this written as
user defined functions which can be
called from an SQL query like from a
declarative query you can call into this
imperative piece of code which will get
executed as part of the query so that's
what UDF stands for so to start the
story right if you look at database like
Microsoft SQL Server which is what the
focus of our work has been so far SQL
Server introduced scalar user-defined
functions way back in 2000 as a means
for users to be able to express their
custom behavior you know some of these
custom logic is easier expressed using
imperative code so there was a demand
for it and they introduced this feature
it was good and happy but in a few years
people realized that scalar UDF's are
evil when it comes to performance so
they're good when it comes to modularity
and code reuse and some other metrics
but with respect to performance it turns
out that they're evil and it's the evil
is not my choice of the world but these
are articles which people have written
sweets and treats and blog posts and all
that on the internet you will find a lot
of those articles and this is not
specific to SQL Server this thing is
common to all relational databases but
our focus was a sequel server so it
turned out that yeah it went to such an
extent that we ourselves as Microsoft we
had to advise our customers to avoid
using user defined functions
whenever performance mattered to them so
let's clarify evil means slow yeah so
that's just an indictment on our culture
we have zero patience
I mean time is money for corporations so
it does matter but really we're talking
slow yes all right so I interrupted this
story and you were at the point where we
said Microsoft said don't use yes blog
posts in MSDN and our own blog engines
that we advised customers to avoid using
UDF's so there was a lot of this
negativity which was there and that
continued even till I mean there are
articles even till 2016 and so on where
people have kept complaining about it so
this was around 2010 I think and that
was when I had joined my PhD at iit
bombay and around 2012 this other PhD
student with my advisor who had then
moved to iit hyderabad another iit in
india and we started working on this
idea of a way to optimize such user
defined functions so this was a
collaboration with a bunch of people and
we came up with the publication in 2014
which was sort of one of the first
papers that said you know you can
actually optimize these user-defined
functions that run in a database and I
graduated in the same year 2014 and
joined Microsoft in Madison where we
have this lab called the gray systems
lab and in 2015 this was in the back of
my mind as to how can I take my ideas
that I had worked on during my PhD and
how can I make them real in the context
of Microsoft's products or services so
that's when I was inspired by this paper
that we had written about UDF's and I
said ok can I try to implement this or
make this real inside of SQL Server so I
started building a prototype and that's
where Freud was born was I started
building the prototype inside Microsoft
sequel server and after a year I showed
it to some people and that got people
interested and more people joined the
team to help me with this and we were
able to convince the product team that
this is an improvement that should be a
part of SQL Server and so then we went
on towards productizing it and in 2017
we had this publication that we brought
out in vldb which is one of the popular
database systems vldb
real DB yeah yeah this is one of the top
tier database
and conference and then in 2018 I moved
back to Bangalore and in the same year
later in the year we publicly announced
Freud as a feature of SQL Server 2019
and we allowed users to start using a
beta or a preview version of this and we
have received like really positive
feedback and response from users who
have tried it out and that's where some
of the users said that it's now magic
and all that so those are again
responses that we got over the internet
or tweets and other social media so it
took a while but you know I think we are
at a point where we have made some
significant progress in that direction
well we've kind of buried the lede here
as they say in journalism and we were
talking about this project called Freud
FR o ID not Freud like the psychoanalyst
yes although software problems could put
you on the couch so tell us sort of
high-level because I'm going to ask you
next to get us into the technical weeds
but tell us what Freud is specifically
so Freud is basically a framework for
optimizing these imperative programs
inside of a database system so database
systems are known for optimizing SQL
queries and running SQL queries but not
imperative programs since the
performance cap yes so Freud basically
tries to address that gap by coming up
with a novel way to optimize imperative
user-defined functions inside of a
relational database so that's like the
one sentence description if you will and
that's perfect as a segue into how you
did this let's go into the weeds and
talk about Freud in more depth how
technically did you bridge the gap
between these two frenemies of
declarative SQL and imperative UDF's
with Freud yep so as I was mentioning
the intuition comes from this paper that
we wrote the way back in 2014 and the
key intuition is that the imperative
programming paradigm and the declarative
paradigm are in two different levels of
abstraction in which you're dealing with
the system so in order to bridge this
gap we come up with an automatic and a
systematic way
- take these imperative programs and
translate them into equivalent
declarative programs or equivalent
relational algebraic expressions to be
more precise yeah so in essence we are
taking imperative programs and
translating them into a declarative form
so now you are in the same world where
SQL and your imperative program are both
expressed in a declarative form so now
that you are in the same world
today's database query optimizers can
understand what's going on inside the
user-defined function and also be able
to efficiently execute those so the key
idea to summarize is that we show how
you can systematically and automatically
translate imperative programs into a
declarative form which is relational
algebra in our setting hence bridging
the gap between the two and gaining
performance with UDF abstraction levels
in a sequel environment yes so we have
done several experiments on many of our
customer workloads as well as benchmarks
and so on and we have seen really
significant order of magnitude
performance improvements because of this
bridging of this gap mainly in
situations where users are having this
trade-off between good code and modular
code and performance yeah with this now
we are able to say that users can still
write code in the way they like and
maintain all the good programming
practices and not compromise on the
performance aspect of it alright so give
us an overview of the stats because
they're pretty impressive give us a sort
of verbal dashboard since this whole
thing began with the dashboard on how
freud has performed comparatively
against the other paradigms yeah as i
was mentioning we have tried tried on
several workloads and even and many of
our early adopters who have already
dried out freud have started writing a
lot of articles about it where they have
done the comparison themselves on their
workloads and it's very heartening to
see others who are trying this out on
their queries and UDF's and finding
positive results so we have seen like I
said orders of magnitude of up to you
know even hundreds of times faster or
even more than that in several cases and
also the other interesting thing is the
larger your database is
the more improvements you get in
performance oh really so for smaller
datasets this may not even matter a lot
because your anime dealing with a small
data size yeah it starts mattering all
the more when you have larger datasets
which is more often the case nowadays
right so people have huge databases with
terabytes of data and being able to
efficiently crunch through these large
volumes of data is critical in a short
amount of time in a sort of short enough
amount of time yes yes can people get
this code yeah so fraud is available as
part of Microsoft SQL Server 2019 beta
or a public preview release which is
available for download on the Microsoft
sequel server website yeah so people can
download it and try it out and we're
happy to get any feedback or any
thoughts that people may have about it I
would encourage people to try this out
and let us know what they think about it
what's on the horizon for the future of
Freud what are the open problems still
and how are you tackling them as
researchers and developers and engineers
yeah Freud is just a first step in my
opinion this is still a long way to go
currently Freud has some limitations in
terms of the kind of functions that it
can optimize right so one of the main
limitations being we don't handle loops
at this point like if your imperative
UDF has a loop inside it we currently do
not do it but that is actively being
worked upon and we have some ideas and
we have some prototypes that we are
building to address that and that is one
of the areas and the other is also to
expand this to a broader set of
languages currently we can do this for
transact-sql or the procedural
extensions of SQL but we plan to expand
this to languages like C sharp and
Python and so on which are used in
contexts of machine learning and data
science and so on so we want to broaden
the scope in those directions and those
are active research threads that are
happening now some people have called it
magic where you are now what do you go
to in the next 20 years
[Music]
this is about the time where I asked the
question is there anything that keeps
you up at night and they don't seem to
be too many looming issues that should
scare us about databases perhaps there
are some things we want to be mindful of
as we outsource more of our
decision-making to our understanding of
data dashboards what's your thinking on
that is there anything keeps you up at
night well I think you know to put it in
a different way right even today what a
database says to a user is hey talk to
me in SQL right and then if you talk to
me in SQL I can do what you want me to
do as efficiently as I can so that's in
some sense a narrow restriction that the
database expects users to talk to it in
a specific way right I think what keeps
me interested or keeps me thinking is
that people will talk in different
languages and they have different ways
to express their requirements and as a
database system we have a lot of good
technology which is built in over the
last several decades which have gone
into these systems and I think there is
a opportunity to broaden the scope or
the reach of databases database systems
by accepting that this diversity of
languages and trying to make the
technology of databases reach to a
broader set of users who may not be SQL
experts right so even if I don't know
SQL I should be able to get the best out
of a database system which is not
entirely true today
Freud takes one step towards that but as
I said it's still a long way and that's
something that I mean making databases
more user friendly or programmer
friendly in some sense or you know more
broad is something that I keep thinking
about and that's the direction I want to
keep pushing through on even if I don't
know SQL very well I should be able to
get the best out of a database system
and today that's not entirely true
so you may not be losing sleep over it
but it's certainly something that
motivates you yes good sleep so I
usually ask people to tell us about
themselves right now mm-hmm
and how they came to MSR but you
basically covered that earlier on is
such a good story so let's get a little
more personal here
what's one interesting thing maybe a
trade a characteristic a life event that
people might not know about you that may
have influenced your career as a
researcher yeah one thing that I can say
is that you know I listen to a lot of
music especially Indian classical music
and I also play the tabla which is an
Indian music instrument and since a
young age that has been my hobby and it
has been with me in inexplicable ways I
think that has sort of enriched my life
and also whenever I want I get
rejuvenation and you know I get
refreshed whenever I go back to music so
although I can't explicitly quantify how
it has helped my career and research and
so on I think it has played a very
important role in my life as a whole and
I keep continuing to go back to music
especially you know I'm fascinated by
the intricacy and depth behind these
highly evolved styles of music one of
which is Indian classical music yeah and
that's something really fascinating and
I keep getting amazed by it that is not
at all where I thought you might go with
this and that is fascinating there's a
big connection between math and music
yes chilling in a little bit there you
say I can't really quantify it and I
love that you can't quantify it because
not everything is quantifiable yes what
do you think was your soul tell you that
music does for your work see I think
there are hidden connections between all
these things that look different on the
surface again as I told you I don't know
what the connection is explicitly but my
gut feel is that there are strong
connections and I don't know what
happens in the brain when you listen to
music I mean it there have been a lot of
studies that try to understand this but
I think overall it has a real
positive impact so yeah all right so
this has been a great conversation as we
close I like to ask my guests to share
something meaningful with our listeners
this could be advice wisdom inspiration
maybe even things I know now that I wish
I knew then is there anything you'd like
to say to would be database researchers
because now's your chance to say it yeah
so over the years what I realized is
that database systems offers like a wide
spectrum of interesting research
challenges and all the more as data
sizes keep growing and technologies like
machine learning and AI are making
inroads into everything that we deal
with on a day to day basis I think as
they become commoditized or democratized
in some sense I think database
researchers have a very important role
to play in how it can be integrated more
easily into applications and software in
general yeah and so I would like to say
that you know as a researcher I think
it's very important to continue to focus
on the fundamentals of you know
principles behind the research that we
do and always keep an eye out for real
problems that practitioners keep
complaining about are the problems that
they face because as researchers and
scientists it's very easy to get
attracted to some intellectually
challenging problems I mean I'm not
saying that's wrong but at least has
applied researchers I think we need to
be cognizant of what's happening on the
ground we need to be grounded by you
know what are the problems that users
face or what are the directions these
technologies are taking us and where
there are gaps to fill so I think
balancing this between intellectually
challenging problems and practically
relevant problems is something which is
very important at least for Applied
Research areas I think sort of the
balance between the solution in search
of a problem and the problem in search
of a solution yeah Karthik Ramachandra
thank you so much for joining us today
it's been awesome
it feels great talking to you thank you
so much
[Applause]
[Music]
to learn more about dr. Karthik
Ramachandra and how fried is delivering
the best of both worlds to database
users visit microsoft.com/testlabguides
[Music]